Speaker 1: We were on the ground in Pickens,
South Carolina, for Donald Trump's 4th of
July weekend rally.
Our correspondent Luke Beasley was there.
Now, if you've been following the show for
a while, you know that Luke's done some wild
interviews.
I believe they all pale in comparison to what
Luke saw there this weekend.
And Luke's done a great job.
But the level of nuttiness and cultish ness
that we saw there this weekend is something
to behold.
This is likely the best and worst one ever.
Now, remember, you can find Luke's YouTube
channel at David Packman dot com slash Luke.
Luke and I strategized before this event and
I said it might be useful.
It might be interesting to focus in specifically
on the indictment and the audiotape of Trump
admitting to crimes.
I was shocked myself at how insane the answers
from these folks were.
Let's start with this first guy.
Completely confused, understands nothing.
Cannot think.
Quite frankly, shocking.
He can even get dressed in the morning.
Listen to.
Speaker 5: This.
What are your thoughts on the federal indictment?
My thoughts?
Oh, I'm not worried about.
Not worried?
Like you don't think he did what he's being
accused of once he was once this indictment
being accused of it, it's like, you know,
they hand out documents like cookies.
Yeah, well, he's only been indicted twice.
I mean, like, so you have the Manhattan D.A.
and then the federal.
Oh, that Manhattan D.A.
He got a piece.
I mean, a porn star.
I mean, it looked every rich person had sex
with a porn star.
Yep.
Already family values are already a family
values, right?
I mean, I've had sex with a porn star.
Oh, God.
Speaker 4: Here we go.
Speaker 1: Really?
Really.
You know, I'm not going to comment on that.
Okay, You judge for yourself.
Whether this young man had sex with a porn
star.
Speaker 5: All right.
And you would be a good candidate in the party
of family values.
You know, we all make mistakes.
Show me a man with no convention conviction
of the past.
You know, show me a man.
Speaker 1: Who I mean, I have no convictions
in my past.
Speaker 5: Is never said a customer.
Show me a man that's never, you know, had
perverted.
Speaker 2: Thought.
Show me a man.
Speaker 5: Perverted thoughts about their
own daughter like Trump and people like you.
I think I was a joke.
He said that on The View.
Speaker 1: They'll defend anything.
Anything he'll defend.
Speaker 5: And that was on The View.
And he said he would like to he said if he
was dating somebody, he would date a woman
like his daughter.
And the most reading recent reporting says
that.
Speaker 1: They're defending Trump, fantasizing
about his own daughter.
Speaker 5: Folks, White House, he has been
overheard fantasizing about having sex with
her.
How does that relate what's going on right
now?
I just think it's gross.
But but you asked me, what do I think about
his indictment?
I know he's a porn star.
So here we are.
Look, I mean, look, we've all looked at porn.
We've seen.
There you go.
Oh, you know, we're just really going.
Speaker 1: So what I this is the first clip
I saw from what looks at me and I said, oh,
my goodness, if this is what this is going
to be like, this is going to be crazy.
It actually gets even more nuts.
Here is a guy, Luke explains, What about ism
to this guy?
And the guy doesn't get it and just responds
with more.
What about ism?
I mean, there's an inability to be able to
think here.
Speaker 5: Arguments.
What about ism?
Speaker 4: No.
What is it?
Speaker 5: It's a logical fallacy when you
try to respond to someone's argument and kind
of break down someone's argument by just referencing
something else separate from the conversation.
Speaker 4: I do that all the time.
I have looked.
You can't talk to us.
Speaker 5: Or what about others are right
there.
Speaker 4: No, the point is you can't talk
to a liberal.
Speaker 5: You're talking to one right now.
Speaker 4: Don't be silly.
I could wrap you around my finger in 2 seconds.
The bottom line is careful.
Speaker 5: I don't know what that means, okay?
Speaker 4: What it means is you've been lying
so long, you don't know how to tell the truth.
But it also means is you've.
Speaker 1: Stayed really quite aligned.
That applies to Trump, right?
You've been lying so long, you don't know
how to tell the truth.
Speaker 4: You stay in China and insanity
for so long, you still don't know how to tell
the truth.
So we're unraveling it.
It's like a piece of thread on the sweater.
So do you agree?
And you guys are losing.
Speaker 5: Do you agree?
The Espionage Act outlines certain things
you can and can't do with classified material?
So why do you agree on an audio, don't you?
Speaker 4: The same thing for.
Speaker 5: Barr, because we don't.
You have evidence that he did the same things
Trump did.
Speaker 4: Not only did he do it, he had no
authority to do it as vice president.
Speaker 5: He obstructed investigation.
Speaker 4: Classified anything you wanted
as president.
But this piece of dreck can't do anything
as vice president.
Speaker 5: Just let's bring the key down.
And just let me ask an honest question.
In the recording that's been released now,
you can hear Trump saying, this is still classified.
I could have declassified as president, but
I didn't know.
Okay.
He didn't know.
I didn't know.
No, he did know.
He did.
Speaker 4: Know.
It doesn't matter.
Speaker 1: He said he didn't know or it doesn't
matter.
But why isn't Biden in prison by now?
Speaker 4: He talked to the FBI months earlier.
Speaker 5: Said, give us the documents, give
us a I can help.
Speaker 4: You know the problem?
You guys are creating a mountain out of a
molehill because you don't want him to run.
That's how stupid you are.
You're afraid that all this is going to materialize
on a much bigger scale.
And he gets alerted.
That's why you guys can't handle it.
Speaker 1: This guy is really a piece of work.
And when Luke confronts the exact same guy
with facts about what Trump did, the substance
of the indictment, the guy says, Grow up and
mentions China.
I'm not kidding.
This is these folks vote.
So we've got to make sure we're voting.
Speaker 4: And the people that are in charge
are so evil and so disgusting and so fascist.
All of us are vulnerable, including you.
If they don't like you, just look at what
they're doing.
The Trump just realize that.
Speaker 5: But like, I would never hold on
to classified documents and then lie to federal
authorities and then disrupting investigation
and then conspire with staffers to hide the
contents.
Speaker 4: Right.
Grow up, please.
Okay.
That's our priority.
Look what's going on around the world.
China.
Russia.
Speaker 1: So what about.
Speaker 4: Worried about documents?
Speaker 1: Yeah, more.
What about ism there?
As you can see, the next guy confidently says
the indictment is garbage, but he hasn't read
it and says the audio recording is garbage.
But he didn't listen to it.
And then when he gets pinned up against the
wall with facts, he says, Doesn't everybody
do the same thing that Trump did?
Speaker 5: What are your thoughts about the
Trump indictment?
Oh, it's probably garbage.
Probably garbage.
Read it now.
Okay.
And then what about the audio recording that
got released?
Probably garbage.
You didn't listen to it.
How did you know it's garbage if you don't
even look into it?
Some serious things are being accused here.
Tell me what it is.
Mishandling and classified documents holding
on to them when he was supposed to have them
for violating a subpoena, lying to federal
authorities, obstructing an investigation
and conspiring with other staffers to move
around documents to keep federal dollars from
getting them.
Speaker 1: So it's like stealing a candy bar,
guys, come on, man.
Speaker 5: Sounds it sounds pretty.
Speaker 4: Serious, but.
Speaker 5: Doesn't everybody do that?
Speaker 1: This would be a comedy if it wasn't
so serious and so tragic and so sad.
Doesn't everybody do all that exact same stuff?
All right.
Then we go and we hear from a woman who is
suspicious of the audio recording of Trump
admitting to crimes.
She's suspicious that it even really exists.
She's like, there is no audio tape.
That's weird.
And then another woman pops up and they both
seem really confused.
And you'll notice they don't know anything.
They use words whose meaning they don't understand
that there's their mouths are moving.
I hear noise.
I recognize the words.
They don't know the meaning of these words.
Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Well, it's like, why do they have
an audio recording?
I mean, that's like going back to Superman
with, you know, also against the reporter
carrying a little recorder.
Why couldn't they have video that kind of
had him on video, but they didn't.
You know, so it's just it's plus, he has the
presidential he has no discretion.
Speaker 1: He has no discretion.
She doesn't even know what she's saying.
Speaker 2: Ever.
He can take his you know that the records
have presidential.
Yeah.
And protect.
Speaker 5: But he has been charged with the
Espionage Act.
Right.
Or violinist.
Speaker 2: Now, here he is.
Everything.
He had them come to his.
They.
They had the opportunity to go through everything.
Right.
And they told him just to put some better
locks on.
And they came back.
You know.
There you go.
He has the right as a president to certify
and do a declassify.
This is Obama's fourth run.
Speaker 1: Yes.
There you go.
But Obama is running for the fourth time right
now.
Speaker 2: Obama now it's his fourth presidency.
Speaker 5: He's controlling stuff.
Speaker 2: Yeah, absolutely.
The only thing Obama hasn't checked off of
his list yet is freedom of speech.
He wants that gone and he's campaigning everywhere
on every platform he can get on.
And that's one of the main things.
Weaponize the FBI, weaponize.
Speaker 1: So what's interesting is some of
the vocabulary of the conspiracy theories
has trickled down into their brains.
They just don't really understand it or know
how to use it.
Speaker 2: Arrests and freedom of speech and
guns, all of that.
He does drag on his little checklist and that's
what he's doing.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's actually it's quite
fitting that this interview is being done
in front of a row of about a dozen porta potties
because everything coming out of the mouths
of these people really deserves to be flushed
10 to 15 times.
Then speaks to two more women who say the
tape doesn't exist.
And it must be I. It must be.
Actually, it's not really Trump.
If there is a tape, it's I.
Speaker 5: Okay.
And then one of the big things in the news
right now is that tape of Trump caught on
recording.
Speaker 2: That that has been debunked, that
it doesn't exist.
Have you not heard that that tape does not
exist?
Speaker 5: I heard it.
It doesn't fake like a Trump voice.
Speaker 2: It must be.
Must be.
They tried to produce it and they couldn't
produce it because it does not exist.
Speaker 5: Even though I listened to it.
Speaker 2: It might have been, I don't know.
But they tried to produce the actual tape.
There is a I think there's there's film, but
there's no sound.
Speaker 1: There you go.
In fact, there is there is no video that I'm
aware of.
Speaker 5: When Trump got asked about it,
he just said, No, no, no.
In the recording, I he didn't deny that.
He said all the things in the recording.
Why wouldn't he say, oh, that was fake if
it was fake?
Speaker 2: I'm not in his head.
Speaker 1: That's a good question.
Even Trump's not denying the authenticity
of the recording.
He's just saying he wasn't really showing
anybody papers.
I don't know.
I don't know what Trump's thinking.
Fascinating stuff.
Then we go to a guy.
This guy is probably racist, is my sense.
This guy refers to Luke as boy is that.
Hey, boy.
Let's listen.
Speaker 5: To what.
Speaker 4: A man is talking.
Is the only person alive on this earth that
can save this republic peacefully, peacefully,
peacefully, right now.
If he's not elected, you listen to this boy.
Speaker 1: Folks, this is not an actor.
Central casting, right as Trump likes.
This is not an actor, as far as we know.
Speaker 4: Republic shall survive regardless
of what the hell it takes.
Okay, Dad, over in your pipe.
Speaker 5: I'm smoking it.
Okay.
Speaker 4: The guy says to look.
Speaker 1: Smoke that in your pipe.
He says in calling Luke Boy.
He says, Trump's the only guy who can peacefully
save us.
But if he loses, then all bets are off.
And it's very much not going to be peaceful.
And the last guy Luke spoke to.
This stuff needs to be in the National Archives.
Really?
Luke speaks to a guy with no shirt on who
hasn't read the indictment, hasn't heard the
audio, but he has really strong feelings about
both.
Speaker 5: Do you think Wokeness.
I hear a lot about Wokeness on the right.
Is that a big problem?
Like being woke like these woke companies?
Yeah.
For.
How would you define a woke woke?
Like, leave the damn kids alone, That's for
sure.
That pisses me off, right?
Well, kids, leave the kids.
Dude, I don't want to get into this too deep
and stuff like that, because I do go to carry
on.
But basically, just being woke, like you're
just shoving crap down our throats.
Like, you have to do this, and you have to
do that, and you have to obey this.
And you can't say that because Sally over
there is going to get offended and you can't
read this book, you can't be gay, etc..
Yeah, dude, all sorts of things.
And it's annoying.
I'm sick of it.
I just want people to be happy.
There you.
Speaker 1: Go.
And then then they actually get to the part
about the indictment here years up.
Speaker 5: So with the indictment, have you
read it or and have you heard the audio recording?
That's been a big thing in the news lately.
Not too much in-depth about it.
So it's a little strange to me since it's
like such a big thing against him.
And he's saying that Biden's weaponizing the
government against them, you know?
So then I want him to get to know if that's
happening or not.
No.
Yeah.
I mean, like, it totally, totally is.
It's just like with Trump having to go to
court on multiple different occasions for,
like all this stuff that the venues are doing.
You know what I mean?
With Hunter and Joe and all these trades and
the sick crap that's going on, you know, and
then it's just like it's kind of like, Hey,
look over here.
Look at look at Donald Trump, you know, like
we're arresting him and we're doing this and
that while they're doing all that crooked
stuff somewhat.
Do you agree that right now they don't have
hard evidence, otherwise they would be broadcasting
it on Fox News?
James Comer admits we don't have the evidence
right now, but we think we have the evidence
against Biden, I should say.
Yeah, I mean, it's totally there.
So then what?
And they'd be like, Oh, wait, you think?
Yeah.
I mean, I think that the stuff is there.
It's one of those things that, like, I feel
like they got to, like, put it out in a certain
way, like a strategic.
Speaker 1: They've got all the evidence against
Biden.
They're just waiting three years to put it
out.
Speaker 5: Kind of way.
You can't just like blasted out there because
maybe stuff gets like spoiled or some sort.
You know, it's just like, put this way.
Speaker 1: It's like if you leave if you if
you leave Mayo out too long, it spoils.
Same thing with the evidence against Biden.
Speaker 5: You agree that I right now can't
see the evidence that's being referred to.
I can't listen to the recordings that are
being made.
Yeah, no, I understand in that sense, some
people would think maybe Trump we can read
the evidence in the indictment, what they're
alleging, and then hear the audio, which is
one of the piece of evidence ourselves.
We can listen to it.
We can't do the same with the Biden stuff.
So maybe the Biden stuff is actually Republican
trying to distract from the Trump stuff now.
Yeah, honestly, dude, I feel like at this
point, we just don't know until it actually
happened with the indictment.
Speaker 1: Until what?
Right.
There may not be an indictment that happened.
That's the whole point, because it doesn't
appear as though they have any evidence against
Joe Biden.
Incredible work by Luke.
This is what we're up against and we have
to support independent media.
So remember, you can go over to Luke's channel,
David Packman, dot com slash Luke and subscribe.
Please make sure that you're subscribed here.
Last month in June, a record three and a half
million people watched our videos but didn't
subscribe.
It's free to subscribe on YouTube.
Support the work we and others are doing.
It is so important.
Make sure that
you do that.